hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein rezept ein wunsch
rezept von mir und zwar gibt es mit
rätseln und spitzelt es ist so ein
hefeteig mit einer mond füllung und den
gibt's zum beispiel beim bag kam also
viele kennen den wahrscheinlich vom
bäcker und heute machen wir die version
besser als beim bäcker und zwar mache
ich den mit einem hefeteig
und ich glaube das habe ich eben schon
mal gesagt aber egal auf jeden fall habe
ich hier vorne schon mal die zutaten für
den hefeteig danach kommen die zutaten
für die mundspülung und dann nochmal für
die streusel also es wird ein sehr
leckeres rezept es ist nicht so
aufwendig und falls ihr euch schon mal
ein hefeteig getraut hat sollte dies
unbedingt heute tun also für den
hefeteig brauche ich einen würfel hefe
zwei esslöffel warmes wasser 80 gramm
zucker 500 gramm mehl 200 milliliter
milch einen teelöffel salz 1 81 gramm
zerlassene butter so erfreue mich jetzt
die hefe und die löse ich jetzt gleich
in wasser auf das dafür zerbröselt ich
sie in die rührschüssel und gebe auch
direkt das warme wasser mit dazu und dem
zucker
ich mache es ganz heute in der kennwort
und zwar mache ich da immer ganz gern
hier verteilt drin weil die kälte hitze
funktion hat und da kann ich direkt
während den kneten sturm auf 30 grad
schalten und dann geht der hefeteig
einfach etwas schneller aus aber
natürlich können sie es auch in anderen
küchenmaschine machen oder einfach
direkt mit der hand verkneten wird auch
selbsthilfe kurz mit dem zucker auflösen
jetzt gebe ich gleich die milz mit dazu
und auch direktes gesamte mail
und da kann es auch sein dass sie etwas
mehr mail benötigt es kommt nämlich
immer darauf an wie groß ist dass sie
benutzt dann noch das 100 das salz und
die butter gebe ich je machen schluss
mit jetzt schalte ich auch hier direkt
30 grad
zum schluss machte butter mit rein
der teig ist dann fertig wenn er nicht
mehr am schlüssel rand klebt und der
durfte jetzt so etwa ablesen
13 minuten treten lassen also mindestens
acht minuten solltet ihr ihn schon
kneten je länger umso besser heraus und
formen zu einer kugel wie hast du ja in
den letzten 7 jahre unsere ehe auch zur
kugel geformt
ich kann das jetzt etwas mehl in eine
schüssel gebt den teig wieder mit hinein
und bedeckte ihn auch mit etwas mühe
kugeln formen das ist mein hobby nach
dem kochen und backen
jetzt stelle ich die schlüssel an einem
warmen ort das mache ich jetzt hier in
der kern wird einfach und deckt den teig
auch ab wenn der monat mit diesem deckel
gibt und in der zwischenzeit kann ich
jetzt schon mal die mond füllung
zubereiten und zeigt euch da vorne die
zutaten anzuraten brauche ich 500
milliliter 180 gramm zucker 40 vom
speisestärke 200 gramm blauen der ist
jetzt noch nicht gemalt eine prise salz
und etwas vanille extrakt bei dem moniz
so den können sie auch gemahlen kaufen
ich mal den am liebsten selbst da hat
man einfach noch dieses schöne aroma
aber male muss man ihnen auf jeden fall
denn ansonsten kommt das auch mal erst
mal gar nicht raus das mache ich jetzt
hier in der gewürzmühle und benutzte
dafür einen trichter denn ihr kennt mich
von dämonen mich da drinnen
was ist wenn wir keine gewähr genau da
muss man fertig gemalt geholfen auf
jeden fall mixa
das funktioniert nicht also habe ich
auch schon mal ausprobiert als
alternative aber das geht wirklich nah
dass ich einfach viel zu feiern
und da braucht man wirklich nicht
gewürzen wie dafür vielleicht ein buch
liest hochleistungs mixa das könnte
vielleicht aber ich weiß nicht ob es
noch nicht ausprobiert kann man
vielleicht jugendbuch ein videobeamer
draufschlagen die ganze zeit nicht alles
klein gemeinsam geht es ja das macht
jetzt dem rat gleich mit der zweiten
hälfte
du kannst vielleicht eine börse machen
ja in einem mörser wird funktionieren
hier hab ich zeige euch jemand den
unterschied hier einmal ungemein das
sieht man schön diese kerne und dann
gemalt und geschmacklich es halt auch
noch dran richtig geschmack ich es halt
echten unterschied wo heute campana
seien gezogen
die patienten völlig jetzt und roman auf
die zweite hälfte
das ist so richtig feuchte und deswegen
liebe ich diesen mond steht so weil er
einfach feucht und locker ist und sehr
lecker
vor allem mit dieser pohling führung
ich mag dem rad ja gar keine kuchen mit
mohn nein ich werde dich heute vom
gegenteil überzeugen man schauen dass
ich mag darf ich kurz aus sprich mag
keine montagen
jetzt will ich die milch in einen
kleinen topf einfach nur ein bisschen
dann kann ich sie nämlich gut mit der
strecke verrühren
manchmal ist halt doch lustig und gebe
ich da eine prise salz mit dazu um den
süßen geschmack zu heben und etwas
vanille extrakt ich finde mode und
vanille passt wirklich perfekt zusammen
jetzt noch den zucker mit rein
er hob sommer die restliche milch lassen
wir es erst mal kurz aufkochen gemeinsam
mit dämonen also den auch direkt mit
rein und jetzt ruhig einfach so lange
bis dieser pudding einmal auf gekochtes
der pudding dürft jetzt einmal aufkochen
und jetzt fühle ich die masse um damit
sie etwas abkühlt und es ist jetzt keine
normale typische mond füllung also wie
man sie kennt das ist jetzt nicht diese
normale mond fülle sondern einen mond
putting und den hits gemacht weil er
einfach später etwas saftiger ist eine
normale mond füllung geht aber auch da
hat man einfach bisserl weniger milch
drin und keine stärke und jetzt habe ich
das ungefüllt damit schneller abkühlt in
der zeit kann auch der hefeteig in ruhe
aufgehen es dauert noch immer etwa eine
halbe stunde und den pudding decke ich
jetzt mit etwas zwischen alte folie
absolute an der oberfläche keine
hoffnung geben etwa einer halben stunde
wieder
der hefeteig ist jetzt richtig schön
aufgegangen und die mond füllung die
jetzt auch etwas abgekühlt gebe ich den
hefeteig auf meine bemehlten
arbeitsfläche
troll ist daraus ein rechteck weißt du
eigentlich noch etwas mit auf tour
geschafft entweder glück oder nein heute
leider kein übt sondern das heißt noch
typisch also nicht folgten wieder wo was
sie cookies in der türkei sind cookies
also nie verwechseln wir machen jetzt
ein paar sprünge so einfach zu einem
großen rechteck aus rolf es hat so etwa
60 zentimeter jetzt kommt die abgekühlte
mond führung drauf
und dann verteidigt es schön nur dass
ich hier unten einen rand frei damit ich
das gleich auf rollen und ankleben kann
und da gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten um den aufzuräumen man
könnte ihn entweder von beiden seiten
auf rollen dann hat man später wie so
eine brille
man kann ihn nur von einer seite auf
rollen man keinen aufholen und so lassen
oder auf rollen und aufschneiden und ich
glaube ich heute einfach auf
jetzt habe ich mich dazu entschlossen
das doch von beiden seiten aufzurollen
deswegen streiche ich die fülle noch bis
ganz vorne
ich glaube das wird zwar einfach etwas
hübscher also jetzt einfach von beiden
seiten auf holz
dann setze ich den mond rätsel auf dem
backblech und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
dieses gelochte backblech mit backpapier
drauf damit darauf dass ich den jetzt
bist du in wellen liegen
und jetzt muss ich noch die streuten zu
bereiten als er schmeckt so schon
richtig gut aber ich finde mit streusel
ist dann richtig komplett für die
streusel brauche ich nur zwei drei
zutaten und zwar habe ich hier vorne 150
gramm mehl 100 gramm butter und 100
gramm zucker und das machen mit ganz fix
hier ohne maschine so jetzt versuche ich
zuerst mal butter und zucker geht aber
eigentlich auch direct mail mit dazu das
kann jetzt direkt einfach zu hacken oder
einfach mit den helfen verdienen
und wer möchte kann natürlich auch ein
bisschen meinl extract hinzufügen schaut
sich wieder so wie rapid und dann
vermenge ich einfach alles gut mit dem
händler
das soll stufe 1
die streifen jetzt ankleben bepinselt
den stritzel noch mit etwas stress oder
kombi wird
und jetzt kann ich direkt die streusel
darüber geben und die dann leicht
andrücken
den backofen habe ich jetzt übrigens
nicht angemacht könnte man jetzt machen
aber dann würde ich den schritt selbst
noch mal vorher kurz aufgehen lassen
und ich stelle den gleich in den kalten
backofen und dann kann der mit dem
aufwärmen des ofens einfach noch ein
bisschen auftrieb
jetzt stelle ich den stritzel in den
kasten backofen und stellen backofen auf
180 grad ober unterhitze und da muss er
dann für etwa 35
aber er 40 minuten der mundschutz bis
jetzt aus dem ofen und ich habe in etwa
so eine halbe stunde abkühlen lassen und
im schuhhaus grandios aus und jetzt muss
ich noch mal einen guss machen und zwar
brauche ich dafür nur 100 gramm
puderzucker und eine halbe zitrone
ihr könnt natürlich auch wasser nehmen
aber ich betone bringt einfach noch mal
so ein bisschen frische mit rein rein
das miteinander verrühren
also eins bis zwei esslöffel
doch noch ein bisschen was sollte der
gus schön flüssig sein aber jetzt auch
nicht zu dünnen also so dass man ihn
schön drauf streichen kann und die
ausgepresste zitrone die könnt ihr
übrigens zum beispiel in die
spülmaschine mitgeben
dann habt ihr so ein ganz natürliches
spülmaschinen gebe ich das einfach
direkt drauf
ja ich finde es wirklich besser mit
zitrone als und wenn ich ja auch einfach
etwas fruchtiger das können wir mit
orange machen eigentlich schon auch sehr
aromatisch ich mir so ein original
klassiker aber so ein bisschen abgewandt
finde ich auch gut
das sieht ja hübsch aus bauernhof
gemacht
ein hühnerstall und die hello kitty die
bewachte hühner discover das jetzt
richtig hübsch als komisch aus also also
also richtig also dollar hühnerstall ist
es also kann man die eier rausholen so
dass kehrt ihr später wenn ich werdet
ihr erst einmal morath finde es nicht
schön geholfen ich hoffe deine ganzen
zweifelsohne zweck von wegen mohn und
das schmeckt dir nicht in 2d gezweifelt
diesen weg wer dieses riesending essen
soll das essen wir also von der menge
her ist es ja eigentlich genauso wie
beim 1
und ich muss sagen es oft dann schaffen
wir fast alleine eigentlich das reicht
für 568 versuchen es gemacht wir
schaffen hier auch alleine so ich frag
mich jetzt noch nicht denn gerade
anschneiden soll aber ich glaub ich mach
das ziel
also ich finde ja das muss man immer
frische ist also maximal 45 stunden
ja also ich finde so hefegebäck schmeckt
lauwarm echt am besten ganz frisch jetzt
darfst du probieren und lustig also zwar
die sie dieses schwein obendrauf
zitronig also bitte kein massen den
wenig zu tun
und an dieser mond gigantisch und er
zeige ich ja richtig schön locker und es
ist diese überraschend schuld wie sie
diese streusel obendrauf ist so richtig
knusprig finde ich auch und ich finde
ihn halt echt wunderschön also nun mag
ich jetzt nicht nur wegen dem geschmack
sondern auch wegen der optik weil man
hat halt wirklich diesen ganz tollen
kontrast drin
mit diesem hellen teig und dem dämon und
dann noch diese weißen streifen alles
wunderschön
also jetzt freue ich mich auf jeden
montag na ja heute ist zwar nicht montag
aber ihr könnt das rezept dennoch
nachlesen auf meinem blog auf sase -
blog.de und vielleicht wollt ihr das
rezept nachmachen
wer jetzt nicht so ein riesen mund
aufmachen möchte kann auch nur die
hälfte machen wobei ich den so richtig
gut findet und wenn man den einmal
probiert habe der schnell aufgegessen
aber man kann ihn sogar auch einfrieren
in hefegebäck lässt sich wirklich sehr
gut einfrieren und beim auftauen dann
könnte einfach diesen zuckerguss drüber
machen und damit die hälfte man also
allem die hälfte macht muss man ein
aufteilen würde man nicht nur ein
kleines geht auch ganz logisch
ja also viel spaß beim nach backen und
wir sehen uns nächste mal wieder biss
dann mußt vielen dank
und vielleicht habt ihr noch eine idee
für einen weiteren classic
tschüss